et voilà la première fournée de la
journée est prête et ses viennoiseries
sont un exemple de la multitude de
produits que l'on peut réaliser à partir
d'une pâte à pain démonstration avec le
savoir faire de ce boulanger
intervenants cfa juste pour la fête du
pain pain au jambon piment végétariens
et même pâte à pizza
j'ai fait deux pattes de pâques de pain
avec des dérivés donc on a fait de l'air
de sérieux d'élèves de progresse de
l'huile d'olive et ça nous donne des
titres fauga sa loge en effet aux
piments végétariens et puis là on fait
défaut gas au japon l'assistance se
compose de jeunes collégiens en classe
aide pas ils sont très attentifs
certaines ses élèves trop timide pour
exprimer leur envie d'embrasser la
carrière de boulanger poursuivront leur
cursus au cfa
cette fête du pain sera sans doute
déterminante dans leur choix
ce sont des élèves qui sont rares et
formation professionnelle et guy un
visage plus tard
une
ces formations et
le cfa pour le lycée professionnel les
intéressent et l'âme davantage au
quatrième pour le motiver un petit peu
pour leur avenir alors c'est pour cela
qu'on les a rendus ce matin
mais le véritable chantier se trouve ici
ou laboratoire la fête s'étend jusqu'à
la pâtisserie en présence du président
de la chambre de métiers d'artisanat
collége et apprentis et formateurs du
cfa sont unis au façonnage de
gourmandise on apprend on sait jamais
d'apprendre suffit plus ça apprend là
j'apprends qu'on a fait les minimes
kanem j'ai toujours fait des couilles
la fée des potes des produits qui
parfois sortent de l'ordinaire
cet appétissant croissant rose imaginé
par un des formateurs et bio pour
réduire les calories
il a remplacé le colorant par un légume
un temps d'une saison avec du chocolat
mais nous avons fait aussi office tâche
donc nous allons ajouter de la pâte de
pistache et nouveau mauvais aussi rose
qu'on vous avait constaté mais plutôt
que de mettre des colorants artificiels
ou autres nous allons mettre simplement
du jus de betterave 200 kg de farine
400e une cinquantaine de litres de lait
offert par les partenaires
demain le cfa de rivière salée célèbre
encore le pain une fête nationale
ouverte au grand public